what is going to happen to zorro after
luffy becomes pirate's king dora no
azaro is the favorite straw hat for tons
of one piece fans and we just can't wait
to see him achieve his one goal of
becoming the world's strongest swordsman
but what exactly waits for zorro after
he actually finally defeats dracul
mihawk after the one piece is found and
the world government is taken down what
is left for our favorite pirate crew
while the manga will eventually end we
readers want to imagine the world and
the characters in it living on beyond
that final page will oda give us an
epilogue that gives us a happily ever
after for each of our straw hat pirates
or will there be some sort of
bittersweet twist well that's what we
want to talk about today for one straw
hat in particular for some straw hats
it'll be very easy to imagine what
they'll do in the future there will
always be hungry people and sanji will
always want to cook for them most likely
with tasty fish from the all blue
frankie will never want to stop
tinkering with his machines and building
bigger and better ships even after the
thousand sunny completes its voyage
around the world and with his
immortality soul king brook will
probably give keith richards a run for
his money when it comes to rock star
longevity but today we want to focus on
rodonoa zorro zaro's goal is to become
the strongest swordsman in the world
yada yada but by the end of the series
it's extremely likely that zara will
achieve that goal by facing down his
mentor dracul mihawk once and for all
unlike some of the other straw hat
dreams he has a singular goal and when
that goal is done it's done by defeating
mihawk he will definitely become the
strongest swordsman his life goal will
be completed so what exactly comes next
for him in general zoro's entire
existence is characterized by his
pursuit of strength he's constantly
lifting giant weights and practices his
swordsmanship he's always surpassing his
limits by cutting down stronger and
stronger opponents and he really started
from almost nothing getting completely
washed by mihawk in the beginning but
eventually in his duel with those bones
zoro learns how to cut steel possibly
tapping into haki long before we ever
actually learned about it properly in
the story and now he's tapped even into
conqueror's hockey in wano he has
managed to match the strength of the
legendary kozuki odin by cutting kaido's
nearly invincible scales as well as
learning kinemon's technique for cutting
through flames and now it's looking like
he'll have to fight an opponent he can't
even see as the straw hat pirates are
gonna face off against the blackbeard
pirates and he'll most likely fight
shiryu of the reign someone who can turn
invisible and who knows if this popular
theory is correct as well he may even
fight against someone who inherits
jose's fruit learning to cut the hardest
substance in the world's diamonds what
does someone who pursues strength so
singled-mindedly do after he finally has
become the world's strongest swordsman
what else does zorro have to strive for
oh yeah and speaking of striving for a
big goal though make sure to hit that
subscribe button it's free and we're
also aiming for a million subscribers
there we go but now back to zorro
thankfully when it comes to predicting
what zorro might do in the future we're
not working totally blind here oda
sensei has actually given us a few hints
to work with about what the future might
look like for each of the straw hats in
the sps section of the manga volumes
he's actually provided some
illustrations of what various straw hats
would look like at the ages 40 or 60.
and he generously gave us both a good
timeline and a bad timeline if you
haven't checked out any of these
drawings in the recent sbs definitely go
take a second to uh look at them right
now
they're awesome for the good timeline
zorro ages very gracefully really he
hardly looks to have aged at all say for
a few wrinkles here and there with a
nice comedic touch zorro at age 40
declares that he has mastered the four
sword style and at age 60 he's even
upgraded to five swords now i'm not even
sure i wanna know how he's holding that
fourth and fifth sword but feel free to
let me know if you have any guesses this
goes to show though that zaro's pursuit
of strength doesn't have to end just
because he's the strongest swordsman in
the world even if he overcomes mihawk
and stands above any other challenger
there's still one important opponent
that he'll have left himself i mean zaro
can always continue lifting his
oversized weights and surpassing his own
limits he'll likely maintain his
disciplined training rather than resting
on his laurels after all he's already
achieved so much in the story and that
hasn't changed his razor sharp focus on
improving himself at all so far now as
we've mentioned earlier he has already
learned to cut steel but that's only
really the beginning of what zorro has
accomplished he has helped a lot to hold
his crew together in the toughest
moments such as when usopp left the
straw hat crew during water 7. he's
defeated countless formidable foes like
the legendary warrior from wano ryuma
gaming the fabled sword shoes wii and
also in thriller bark who could forget
him taking on all of luffy's pain in
order to save the rest of the crew and
in a truly iconic moment professing that
nothing happens and recently in wano
like we mentioned he's managed not only
to scar kaido a feat formerly only
accomplished by odin but also to
temporarily block a dual attack from
kaido and big mom he also of course
tamed odin's sword enma and evidently
even fought back the grim reaper himself
and as we enter the final saga zorro
shows no signs of slowing down in the
slightest just like mihawk he may live a
quiet and reserved life though with
barrels of sake i guess instead of wine
he'll keep training constantly waiting
and searching for the time that a worthy
opponent may arise wanting to take the
mantle of world's greatest swordsmen for
themselves kind of becoming the mentor
of someone else however on the opposite
end of things we have the terrifyingly
bad timeline for zorro tragically
somehow he loses his hair along with
several teeth and definitely definitely
has stopped working out at age 40 he's
long given up swordsmanship claiming
that holding that katana with my mouth
makes my back hurt if i were to guess
i'd say this is probably how he lost
those teeth as well if we're being
honest and it's kind of a miracle he
hasn't so far at age 60 things are even
worse in this timeline he's become a
beggar claiming that he'll bow down to
anyone who'll give him some spare change
oh boy we can really only guess what
terrible events could have convinced
zorro to drop his swordsmanship along
with his convictions and most
importantly his honor the zorro when we
know would never bow to anyone after all
he's a conqueror just like his captain
and while oda's drawings give us hints
as to what zoro might do after the story
doesn't tell us at all where he'll be
doing it where could zorro possibly go
after luffy becomes the pirate king and
the thousand sunny stops its voyage but
there are a few options after zoro
dethrones mihawk perhaps he'll
eventually take over as the steward of
kurigan island after shiichibukai passes
on i mean someone has to keep all those
apes company after all however occupying
mihawk's home chateau seems more up
herona's ally for being honest and
something tells me zoro would rather not
spend any extra time with her after all
he's not that keen on that tim burton
goth aesthetic if any of the straw hats
were to look for a home there it would
probably be brooke if we're being honest
i could also see zorro ending up on
sabah odi archipelago taking over
silva's rayleigh's job zorro is the
first mate to the future pirate king so
maybe it would be fitting for him to
follow in the footsteps of his
predecessor the first mate of goldie
roger zorro too could keep an eye out
for the up-and-coming rookies making
their way into the new world and perhaps
even giving them a test of strength
before they descend into the second half
of the grand line given that the grand
line and the one piece world as a whole
as it exists right now is even still a
thing at that point of course another
option could be a return to wano even
though we're just about to leave it
after all it's become clear that zorro
is a shumotsky and even the possible
heir to a daimyo position zoro's way
around katana and the way that he seems
to magically attract wano blades like
the kitetsus the wadoichimonji shusui
and now enma seem to suggest a natural
attraction to his homelands i'm sure
certain shippers in the community would
not be disappointed to see him end up
with yuri either given some of the
chemistry in the wanord that's some
chemistry besides where better to find
tough opponents to spar with than among
the samurai of wano perhaps though zoro
will travel all the way back to the east
blue to his home in shimotsuke village
after becoming the greatest swordsman
he'll visit queen's grave to show her
that he achieved their goal after all he
did it in part to carry on her legacy as
well i mean one truly touching scene
that i could imagine would be him
teaching young pupils at the dojo where
he learned swordsmanship igniting the
same spark in them to become the
strongest that was lit in him as a child
and since we already suggested that
zorro could end up with yuri while we're
shipping we might as well wonder if he
might become closer to tashigi as well
obviously their relationship has been
pretty strained with him comparing her
to kuina and her being a marine and
trying to capture his crew and all but
they both sure do love a good sword so
that's something that they do have in
common or maybe zoro will never settle
down at all something tells me that
luffy will always be up for an adventure
if he's still alive and he'll probably
need his most reliable crewmate at his
side at all times and if you really want
to understand why zoro is so loyal to
luffy and how their relationship has
developed throughout the story you
simply can't miss out on that video
right here